Hey Mark!
>> What is it this time?
>> I've got my million dollar idea.
Okay, you know what's
super hot right now?
>> Uh-huh.
>> Match three games.
So, I thought, what would be even
better then a match three game?
A match four game.
I've got it all sorted out.
I've got all of my matching
code in the main source set.
And then I'm going to
add source sets for
each one of the extra games I'm going to
build with the matching engine right?
So I've got my source set for
my matching candies game.
I've the got the source set for
my matching sushis game.
I've got my source set for
my spider matching game.
>> Yeah, but that's not really
what product flavors are for.
They're for different versions
of what are really the same app.
What you want to do is share
a code between different apps.
So, you really want to
build a project library.
>> Oh.
You're a librarian and
you have to match four books.
Perfect, Mark.
You're a genius.
>> Congratulations on learning how
to build apps with multiple flavors.
That's just the start of how you
can make your apps bigger and
better while keeping them modular and
maintainable.
In the next lesson we'll talk about
Java and Android library projects.
See you there.